[Music]
that navigation of your own uh uh
triggers or your own instincts is what's
gonna make somebody memorable as opposed
to somebody who right would say
i had the
if somebody came afterwards and said
that guy right there did that you go oh
man i was going to say something to him
but you didn't right and that's the
difference between somebody being great
and somebody being so sold
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god
attention listeners you guys ready to be
blown away you asked for it and they
listened our friends at manscaped just
relaunched the ultra smooth package
that's right baby it is back uh your new
favorite tool and compliments to the
lawnmower 4.0 uh your favorites or buzz
razor to keep your boys smooth while
looking and feeling their best this is a
brand new specialized groin shaving kit
it's here to help you buff protect and
shave your most sensitive areas it's
time to crop that bush of yours and get
right to the roots with a discount just
for you from manscaped get 20 off plus
free shipping at manscape.com with the
code omghi
hey everybody producer grant here uh
just telling you what you're about to
listen to what you're about to watch is
part one of a two-part episode with
trevor wallace george and he had a great
time really hit it off turn this one
into two uh so be sure to check out this
episode this week you're about to and
tune in next week for the second half so
without further ado here's part one
sit in here
come on in here yeah
this isn't one of those places where
people are like oh
everybody's welcome everybody's welcome
here do you know gail
which is matt
just met gil is a do you know anything
about him
i'm about to oh yeah you're about to
he's just overweight mexican sitting
right next no no that's true but but
also
that gill
was one of the two detectives that
captured richard ramirez the
nightstalker
dang
dang that's a that's a crit that's a
credit exactly that could be like i mean
if you do the tonight show with johnny
carson or if you do letterman
this is that what would that credit be
like that would almost be no that's
that's performing for the president
almost [ __ ] i don't know i'm just happy
to be here brother i'm nobody special
you know i know you know that
him and his partner there's a
documentary on netflix the not soccer
documentary that that
he's in there dang
and i thought you were cool man there's
no this is like
are you guys into true crime or not are
you guys in the true crime nah i want to
be it sounds cool you are she's a little
bit i want to be she is and you're not
oh why do girls love true crime they
have a fascination with murder
they're like there's something about it
murders are hot you know
it's like there's a fascination behind
it you know because it feels good to be
wanted you know okay
it feels you know where you introduce
our guests i'm already vibing i'm
already of course i love it i love the
vibe already trevor wallace today
joining me here podcast comedian we're
here actor podcaster host the stiff
socks
joining us today we're excited to have
you thank you dude
let's talk about why did you name it the
stiff's uh socks podcast systems podcast
man honestly everybody thinks we have
some like crazy story you know it's just
kind of like me and my buddy the
co-producer we were just riffing like
well he was a buddy from where like how
long have you been doing it i'm standing
up comedy i just know him through comedy
he's a new york guy michael blaustein
also a funny guy in the stand-up world
we met at an open mic like four years
ago
and we were just talking shooting the
[ __ ] and some clicked like our chemistry
we were just talking and talking yeah
and then like the next day he called me
and he was like hey man you want to
start a podcast and i was and you know
you hear that phrase sure of course in
this damn city that's the new uh kind of
like start a band type of thing so it is
what you start yeah
that's modern day it is a new startup
type of thing yeah yeah it is you know
probably about three years ago i was
asked if i wanted to do my own podcast i
don't know nothing i don't know [ __ ]
about this business i don't know nothing
about it
and the offer was there i said ah nah
nah thank you i don't know i don't want
to do this but also i would say that you
don't have to know [ __ ] about anything
other than just being like just have a
chemistry yeah that doesn't matter
that's all that matters because i'm
gonna find you it doesn't matter what
camera you use what a recording if
there's good chemistry people will
listen yeah so we were just riffing
going back and forth back and forth and
then we're like dude we should you know
because i wanted to do one on my own i
was i was going to do it myself talk
straight to the camera edit myself and i
was like that's a lot of work i'd rather
strum a guitar with george lopez but is
that more youtube is that do you play
guitar no i don't but is that more
youtube than podcast or what like like
okay so so i watch uh uh true crime
stuff on youtube like almost all day
yeah yeah and but
is that but i don't listen but i don't
listen to their podcasts so is your are
you guys youtube and podcast yeah and ig
and all that stuff all of it yeah so
yeah we post it on everywhere like our
tick tock is how a lot of people find
our
podcast you know it's like it's crazy to
think that the word podcast sounds so
outdated you know everybody thinks of
like the you know just like transcripts
and old [ __ ] like black and white tvs
but it's like bro we got a podcast wait
a minute wait a minute but what was the
first tv that you had i had a black and
white black and white how how thick was
that boy
boy
but also heavy as hell i remember
some kind of stuff they put in front of
make it look color wait a minute i was
just gonna say that check this out
check this out no no no no not even a
filter they used to sell a [ __ ] piece
of glass yeah thrifty that the top was
blue the middle was clear and the bottom
was green yes so that if you were
watching this show the sky was above and
the middle would be yeah just natural at
the bottom do you remember you could and
attach it to your screen and you would
put stick it to your tv screen oh man so
you said thrifty is that the same place
that does ice cream through cheese ice
cream
exactly
that's the only reason why write it is
still in business is thrifty's ice cream
that thing and thrifty's ice cream was
made by carnation no it was made by this
is the first [ __ ] genius we've had in
here
i had a joke where i went to thrifty's
and the guy goes what are you waiting
for to this to become rite aid yeah
drifty ice cream was the when you got
strawberry had real [ __ ] strawberries
in it it did i love the scooper have you
seen this
it's a pvc pipe glued to a magnum
and you punt you like you literally
force the pecans to get in there get in
there [ __ ] then you pull the scoop in
it and it pulls it out and like a toilet
paper roll
do you remember that thing that they
were dipping in the water yeah
that water was clean you know it's the
same water they'd get to a chihuahua on
their lunch break
my daughter my daughter couldn't wait to
get her hands up and somebody gave her
one for glass christmas big deal they're
selling them now the scoop they look
like
they look like almost fancy feast cans
like they were around yeah it looks like
if you went to home depot you know the i
think it's called uh the cot you know
what it's called
yeah it looks like a caulking gun man
but it works
they know something robin doesn't you
know hey and it wasn't a scooter like
basketball was a scoop that you only
give you that little pink ass [ __ ]
spoon like a semen sample that little
yeah
like if you know if you want somebody to
take a sample you wouldn't you want to
give a bigger scoop than just um oh yeah
that little yeah just a hit yeah if you
want to know if a joint is good you
don't go you go
you get your money's worth there you go
right oh yeah awesome i don't even think
three i would say i like that it's so no
no no like just buy the [ __ ] flavor
they just they just let you look at it
that was the same they do have little
little there's no they do hey that was a
sample growing up they let you look at
it well now because kobe people are like
we're not doing samples and i'm like how
does that have to do with anything with
samples you are just cheap looking
they're saving money there it is there
it is that looks like he did it looked
like a staple gun with some pvc pipe
that was somebody who was being
innovative at home and then like i could
take it
to the general public because if they
did they are [ __ ] they're selling
them now
yeah everybody in my family has one now
i'm gonna buy you one man as a guest
that would be awesome all right i'm
buying everybody in this room dude you
got to make your own you got to come out
with that oh george that is that's just
nice right there man what was your
favorite ice cream growing up
uh uh
orange sherbet oh
chocolate chip chocolate chip
it was either
strawberry or rocky road rocky rogers
can say rocky rocky
yeah the marshmallows because you know
they had real marshmallows in there man
and roll like what they did almost
almonds
chocolate almonds and marshmallows
where do you get your ice cream these
days now it's like some la [ __ ] you know
like have you heard of salt and straw
i saw it or what is that in silver lake
it's one of those places well how many
are there there's a few there's a good
play but they're they're not national
mm-hmm and i don't think so
hey how would an ice cream place be
named salt and straw
tell the truth oh i'd never buy it from
there yeah but i mean that's just
because it's near me but it is tasty
they because but they do like crazy [ __ ]
it's like uh balsamic and pear and
you're like
you know i'm not doing all that i'm not
doing i just go there for like you know
just the double dutch a little bit of
peanut butter you know what i still love
it to this day is cold stone cold stone
is still a classic cold stone and you
you feel like you got a they're working
for all right
like a hibachi grill you know it's the
[ __ ] ice cream
so so for people that don't know cold
stone
so yeah essentially you pick out the
flavor you want and they scoop it with a
i don't know the
like there's like a metal spatula
like they're doing
they lay it literally on a frozen a cold
stone it's like a frozen countertop
almost like a morgue like if the morgue
sold ice cream yeah yeah they would be
whipping
then they spread it out and then you
pick what you want they put it in there
and then they just start they're jumping
into the gang you know they beat the
[ __ ] out of it
like this yeah so they're just beating
the [ __ ] out of it and they fold it all
up and then they just put it in a cup yo
have you been a coal stone i've been
there once and it's got a scent cold
stone has appeared and you know that
scent right yeah they do have a set
there's a cold son of mine there's
always an old lady that works there like
everybody's young also if you tend
there's always one if you tip them they
have to sing
that's what that was
that's the worst part about it no so you
can hold a dollar no they don't know
they don't know i swear george i swear
to you they might as well
they might have stopped but they at one
point that was the thing
look look listen if you ever work there
write in let let's have you ever worked
there
with a number
yeah but if you were working out
probably covered or something but i was
it was like uh that's just hilarious
sonic used to be on roller skates they
don't do that anymore oh yeah come on
why don't you think that
bro i mean look if i worked i'd ask for
a raise every time i was like i survived
today but what about those places man
how come you think that what about our
culture change that like a boss big boy
over there in riverside here yeah or
wherever like sonic they used to skate
what made it about our culture that
made those things sure it's too
expensive you get hurt on the job yeah
somebody falls you fall on the job i'm
looking at my boss and i'm like oh no
i'm losing memory all the blood is
rushing to my head and the guy's like
okay here's a race here's a race a w
used to have or if you roll up and do it
exposed he's got his dick out you're
bringing you know number one over there
and he's got his dick out like seriously
that you know you may think it's the
wrong
wrong dick but sonic still has the two
dudes in the car like they're waiting
for somebody to roll up to the window
yeah sonic they get now they just walk
it out to your car but it is still uh
you still pull up into your own
individual drive-through spot which i
like that's good privacy
yeah interesting
i would rather prefer i think to eat in
the car than i would to eat i think
in-n-out should have that they they do
they ask you that and the card they say
is this to go or in the car that sounds
like an invasion of privacy they just
don't care what i do with this doubles
don't have that big place to park no but
totally yeah but totally they want to
know what you're going to do but and
then they prepare you i lie i'll be like
i got friends at home they don't ask i'm
like i got friends at home and like you
got one cheeseburger i'm like hey man
don't worry about it okay but it does
feel weird to look another man's eyes
back this one's for the car
he's like what's going on man you ain't
got time to sit inside you don't want to
talk to strangers that's true
it sounds weird to like just confess
dude like this one's for the car all
right so where did you where did you
come from uh i was born in illinois but
only lived for two years i spent a lot
do you think he was you're a detective
did you would you say that he was from
illinois why do you sound southern like
i i just don't know why i sound southern
he's saying that he's from white's usa
southern
smart people glenn campbell's smart
[ __ ] oh no i'm messing with you
my dad's from ohio my mom's from but
doesn't he
sound southern wait no it sounds like i
don't think he sounds southern
little southern i don't know i'd say
midwest
uh but i grew up in uh
you know oxnard i'm from out there oh
that's where i grew up ventura camarillo
see get the [ __ ] out i bet you love
strawberries bro i mean you're a legend
out there that like no but there's no
way that i would why do you why do you
ask my parents i don't know because i
grew up in camarillo why do i feel that
vibe from i don't know from you dude
first thing i would have said was the
camera right about there camera yeah you
said what
because you have the hair oh yeah but
camarillo is cool because it's by the
ocean you got the ocean look at that
his voice doesn't sound like anybody
that's been out there he doesn't sound
like he's from uh to me doesn't sound
like i sound like
i think
right i'm going to talk to my therapist
about this
aaron what do you say i i think
you're a detective what do you think
what do you think is what i just think
it doesn't sound like it's from
california i i'd say midwestern but dang
uh but it's i definitely whitening and
it comes from
if he says oxnard i don't know anybody
the only the only people from oxnard
camera who i know are mexican boxers i
mean [ __ ] that's true
so so how did you find your way to stand
up comedy my mom actually suggested i do
it oh my god yeah it's like a disney
channel story wait a minute how does
[ __ ] any everybody's mom says don't
[ __ ] do it but i was coming from a
place i was like smoking weed in eighth
grade like i was not on a good path but
i always wait a minute not a good path
for what
i really think is a good path to stand
up a hundred percent it was a good path
for what i ended up doing but yeah in
eighth grade i was smoking weed out of a
life are you smoking wait a minute we're
out of what out of a light bulb
i swear to god damn like we the dude who
showed me how to smoke weed he broke
the the glass part of a light bulb
drilled a hole anytime you got a drill
to smoke weed that's probably not weed
right so he drilled the hole in the
bottom of the socket and then he put a
pen cap on it and then put that i mean
we used to just make like uh bongs for
fun
bongs
yeah and then we just put the pen cap
and we put it in like a water bottle we
just put it in here and then like
you know so i was more fascinated with
that type of stuff i wasn't really doing
a lot and then but my mom knew i had
like a good personality and i was at
least kind of like always we're going to
be in jokes
but if you're designing bongs with a pen
cap and a [ __ ] light bulb yeah you
ought to be working thrifty protest
risky or kia or thrifty yeah i'll make
i'm within your [ __ ] the scooper i
was on some meth head [ __ ] i won't even
lie we used to just make bongs and show
each other like we'd come to class and
be like yo look at this one all you had
to do was take a pen cap and melt a
metal top into it or a socket my dad
would always be like where's all the
sockets the hours
i was fixing my tech deck but i was just
smoking weed out of it [ __ ] yeah
and and did you build a high tolerance
for marijuana or not back then yeah
because i didn't do have you you don't
smoke weed i don't smoke weed yeah he's
a cop but but he was he wasn't but even
now his officer but he eats a little bit
of it but
but i i
you know what is it about a person's
disposition where
they might be able to smoke five joints
and just not get high or somebody takes
one hit in there we're just talking
about that i got friends who before they
leave the house they take a bong rip and
that's their coffee
it's insane to me it's like the last
time you open up your your capillaries
to more you get higher if you cough yeah
that's the last thing i ever want to do
if i smoke is leave the house lock me
indoors
dim the lights put the cat to bed okay
so so have you driven high and not and
forgot where you were going oh yeah i've
driven high and forgot my own name
can we get a name for the order and i'll
be like tomorrow and then just that's it
you know you know one time i ate like a
little bit of a brownie and i was going
to we were going to catch a flight and i
was driving down sunset i forgot i would
stop the jack-in-the-box right there on
kawenga it was open to kawenga and
sunset oh yeah and i forgot where i was
going when i got out of the drive
through i said where the [ __ ] am i yeah
gps just said
i was going to vandalize a millionaire
in van nuys i forgot
yeah man it's uh oh so
so let's say that that was weed before
weed was uh was legal or not legal or
used this is when you had to hit up
somebody who had an older brother at the
time yeah and whereabouts
and what about now that uh it's legal
do you are you considering your own line
or do you have your own line i think
they'd be called i've been offered to do
like my own line of weed um
you know i i just uh i don't think i
smoke as much as people think i do i'll
smoke probably like a couple times a
month but that's also that's also a
thing too like if you talk about it
people think that you smoke all the time
because you have uh you know like your
your recall or whatever you say about it
is almost like on point so yeah people
think like oh this guy must smoke every
day yeah yeah yeah yeah no i mean i'll
be down to do or i'd come out with some
line that's like an edible version
whether it's like a drink or a gummy or
like a gum or something like there's
crazy [ __ ] i just found out there's
toothpicks that have caffeine and
nicotine in them for people who are
trying to quit cigarettes i'm like
there's so many levels of like
integration i'd be coming out with like
weed toothpicks that'd be awesome
okay you know what i didn't know there
was there's everything toothpicks but
if there were thc toothpicks or cbd and
thc toothpicks
now we're talking about there's gold
that's fun stuff you know who business
george uh uh a few years ago somebody
asked me
well uh a guy said what would you create
that's not out there and i said i will i
said i would create a uh
vix version of cbd and thc which i have
that yeah oh the rub i rub and it works
right i use it i swear by it put some on
last night
i love it aches and pains and all that
good aches and pains just like whatever
you'd use vicks for if you had a cough
last night i was rubbing it on my chest
before i went to bed
and it works out it works feels good and
it's yours it's my tang and there's
other things out there but i'm not sure
if i haven't tried a lot of other things
but the ones that i did try i don't
believe worked as well as the one that i
created
that's awesome you have a lot of stuff
in the cannabis industry um there's some
there's some some joints and stuff
but but the but the san asana i call it
sauna sonic because all the mexican moms
would be going the santa santalita
and that one the guy it just came out
the guy was at my tournament he said
that
there's 56 places in california that
have it and he said that people go in
there and would just buy whatever they
have like they're going there like yeah
like like at cold stream i'll take
whatever you got whatever the whatever
[ __ ] cookies you got was when you
know i had a friend of mine that worked
on my first show bobby and he was into
that vienna coffee remember those vienna
coffees yeah yeah yeah and they stopped
baking them and he went and bought
every [ __ ] cop container of
beyonce because
he hasn't been able to wake up every
morning and not have it so he's got a
thousand containers in this ham i should
have done that with four loco when they
started banning the original one the
ones with caffeine and them yo hey did
you ever drink before local oh yeah you
because when those came out i was in
high school so like because i was
smoking weed earlier i was drinking in
eighth grade so we talked about i was on
a great path i was smoking and drinking
like every weekend so in high school
like my sophomore year we drinking four
local and then go to a woman's
volleyball game and just start yelling
but for us that was like the best
highlight ever you know
that reminds me so much yeah he looks so
of my i have a grandson 22 years old
yeah looks just like you oh yeah
i mean
there you go you have somebody like this
in your family yes i think i did
yeah but i'm glad i got that all out of
me because you know i did that then i
ended up going to college is that all
out of you are you sure ah for the most
part yeah cause like now i'm like i just
you know i'm cool having like a like a
like a nice drink and then that's it you
know i'm not getting too crazy or wild
anymore what do you think what do you
think curbed your your i think i got it
all out of me
can somebody get it all out of them i
think so all i really care about is like
my career and just like trying to be the
best i can be as a comedian i like you
there you go you never said that i've
never said that
he did it i've never said it really no
damn i just i think i got like i saw
this the snowball start to build up and
i was like oh we got some momentum let's
keep this thing going yeah i just you
know that for me i think everybody's got
a vice for me okay the vice is chasing
chasing the dragon get more views you
know what shows get better i appreciate
you know what this is the first person
that we've had in here
since we started this thing almost a
year and a half ago that i've heard that
sat in that chair that said i had this i
want to chase a dragon i'm gonna do that
in that yeah okay so so
where was the first place that you
decided to do
what you probably do
that you that you wrote something
and what led you to the first just only
talk about what from the first pen to
paper yeah
or computer or whatever to your first
performance and where was that at you
probably have done the club the ventura
harbor comedy club yes you ever done
that yeah sure but but what made you get
there like okay so yeah
my mom cut out this thing in the paper
it's literally a scene from a movie it's
like it doesn't seem real she cut out a
scene in the paper and it was like uh
there's a six-week comedy stand-up
comedy workshop class at the ventura
harbor comedy club you should check this
out but when you're 18 or so sorry 17
when you're 17 you don't care about what
your parents were saying i was like yeah
whatever mom that's stupid and then like
one night i was just like thinking about
i was like i'll give it a shot i'll
check it out you know like it's got to
be something you know and who talked
that thing this guy randy lubis
he's been in the industry forever he you
know he he did a heavy road dog then did
a bunch of cruise ships and everything
but he also owned the comedy club so we
went there and it was six weeks it was
every saturday and then you'd be there
for like four hours and he would just do
act uh uh he would like hand you like a
newspaper and they'd be like write a
joke out of that okay what are some big
events in your life what how can i help
you write a joke so essentially over six
weeks they help you write a five minute
set all right
and and i remember the set it was three
topical jokes up front and then a story
about how i went to the courthouse in
oxnard for a skateboarding ticket i
didn't have a helmet i was skateboarding
and the guy next to me was there for
grand theft auto and it was so funny
because one of the only white kids in
the in the uh the courtroom
and my my neighbor told me that if you
bring a helmet to the courthouse when
you get a helmet ticket they excuse you
and the guy before me full-on had like a
mustache and everything we're all 15.
getting there for grand theft auto he's
like you know i plead i didn't do it i'm
not guilty this and that that's a big
dramatic moment and i i stood up and i
held up a helmet and i was like i
brought my helmet with me and i it just
i'll never forget that moment because i
was everyone's there for for real crimes
and i was there for a skateboarding
ticket damn did you get off i got off
yeah
i avoided like 100 tickets
i got off for the ticket and it was in
oxnard california and i and i told a
story about that just what it was like
being next to people who were just like
for real committed crimes
but the ability for you to recall that
situation and in a humorous way just
naturally come to you
um because i think that that i think you
know like
any writer in the beginning
you know you're you're looking at a page
let's say this big yeah and then the
more you write you really look at
there's probably a lot of people looking
at something more specific yeah which i
think uh if you're more specific as a
detective
as a comedian or as anybody wanting to
get in the business if somebody asks you
a question the more you ramble the less
they're interested yeah and the more the
more specific you are i would talk about
my first thing was like you know what i
did why you crying they would say well
why did you pick why you're crying
because my grandmother would always say
why are you crying and she would [ __ ]
hit me and if my ear was bleeding she
would say like oh you walked in here
like that like it was just very specific
yeah and and and for me i was i was less
of a guy that would drag on and more of
somebody that just got to the point yeah
i think i was i had all the tools to
bring this up to the table then it was
like dusting off dinosaur bars like okay
there's good [ __ ] here we've got to get
rid of that the topical stuff up front i
i think i got a knack for it pretty
quick he was like oh okay oh you you're
able to make the comparison so i think
in my head it like that part clicked so
i knew i was like there's funny in this
story i just gotta find the moments i
have the set somewhere on my mom has on
like a vhs so so here's the joke so uh
will smith's laps uh chris rock and that
dude attacks chappelle tell better jokes
you can't
there's nothing funnier than that tell
better jokes
oh right right now that's an activity no
no no i mean if you say oh why did will
smith slap chris rock why did that guy
attack dave chappelle first thing chris
rock said when the guy attacked dave
chappelle says did you check was that
will smith well i was there i was at
that chappelle show yeah i saw it happen
it was not nobody thought it was real
nobody
because like as this was going on
everybody thought that this was like
dave just being dave you know yeah but
then the lights went dark and they took
the dude back there and then things got
quiet they stopped that [ __ ]
forever
i think everybody was getting kicks in
there i think dave because dave came
back and he's like i never stomped
somebody out in my like 37 years of
career or whatever you said but i think
dave was throwing a few kicks back there
too yeah dave looked like he wanted to
go back to her
i think everybody should have it was i
mean it was wild but also you know we're
all susceptible to that at some point or
you know now especially now there's not
something that was new hecklers have
been hecklers forever oh yeah you know
so so but also
um
you know um
i would just say if you if you
worry about your own path
you have more focus than if you worry
about everyone else's path correct yeah
and a lot of times you know communities
are worried about what everybody else is
doing it's hard not to be and it's hard
not to be yeah but also
just do your own thing
and uh you know
that's when i really feel like i'm bold
that the mighty forces will will come to
your aid yeah i stopped focusing on
everybody else what they were doing and
what what the traditional route was
because i you know i make a lot of
videos online and the videos help propel
me
way faster than stand-up so it's like
you know i had probably 25 minutes of
material these videos start taking off
online and now people are like dude you
should just headline go sell your own
tickets you'll make money you can quit
your day job and now i'm trying to
figure out how to compile a headlining
set and then like a year and a half
later i'm not even worried about this
[ __ ] i was worried about a year before
because now i'm doing my own thing i'm
like selling my own tickets i'm
promoting myself i got an agent i got a
manager i'm really just trying to do it
but dana carvey told me in 1987 what's
that when dana carvey was at the ice
house in 1987 he was getting he didn't
even actually finish the week because he
was doing wise guys with uh kirk douglas
and and bird lancaster were both gone
and he got like three uh
um encores the night before
and he was doing this movie at paramount
and i said to him what made you so funny
and he said it's attitude
oh dude you can't believe it they
believe it but also i said how do you
remember all that stuff and he said in
compartments like
if a box had the opening if a box had oh
my god hi then a box had atc and a box
had this beer
that's
30 minutes
a box about this a box about that
and a box about this and you know what
to me because i was
a categorical comedian but the minute
that you started to put the opening in a
box and the and about the doctor in a
box and about allergies in a box yeah
you find the flow
you found the flow yeah and you can't
find the flow connecting one two three
four five
but or six seven eight nine ten but you
can find the flow connecting one ten ten
twenty
twenty thirty yeah yeah and it actually
takes so long and you watch some people
is the whole story from the moment they
grab the mic and i'm sure you're this
way too the moment you grab the mic the
moment you end there's this great
through line of just like
what are the last couple years of your
life looking like or whatever it is and
i see some guys and there's some guys
out there that are so good at it and
then you know as you just you find these
segways and you have to be it's so hard
to go from talking about like you know
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches to
your girlfriend's breast reduction
you're like how the [ __ ] do we get from
here to here but you know what man find
a way but you know what when you have
the confidence you can take the liberty
of doing it yeah oh yeah and there's no
right or wrong way to do it too no no
that's right so so whatever your
or whatever anybody's particular style
would be
you when you're in charge you can tell
somebody
what it's going to be and like guys
would go up and say hey how's everybody
doing tonight
dana carvey said [ __ ] all that [ __ ] you
go up there and you tell them how it's
going to be they don't tell you how it's
going to be
and that sets the precedent as somebody
with that [ __ ]
hey how about a nice round of applause
for the camera here wasn't it great [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you just go up there and just
you you just start
to deploy your will on them yeah and not
them everybody decides how's everybody
doing tonight there's nothing special
about that but last night i went up
mother's day i said where all the milfs
at just write out the game right there
just let them know oh this is
but it catches people off guard too you
know that's what i'm saying
hey they were not there
that's what i'm saying like that i i
would watch you that that's what i would
do but it takes a while it takes a while
you know to but also if it comes to you
in the car or if it comes to you in the
hallway with the improv and you trust
yourself say it the trust is big yeah
the trust is big and some of the best
it's a high risk high reward type thing
is if the act before you say something
and then you get a tag off that coming
in you know like they say something
about just like like if you said
something about like this uh annoying
white kid in your neighborhood then i
came up and i was like oh what's up i'm
that annoying white kid they'd be like
then you can ride that wave well done
all right everybody the legends who
introduced the electric ball hair
trimmer are back bringing their razor to
you so you can be set and trimmed from
front to back that's right manscaped is
back and men you no longer have to
borrow your ladies razor for that nice
precise trim you can get all those hard
to reach areas hard to see areas no
ingrown hairs no cuts no none of that
bad stuff so it's a handy four-step
process here from your friends of
manscape step one grab your handy
lawnmower 4.0 and give your boys the
classic trim to your liking to get the
loose hairs out of the way and then take
out the manscape this is the new thing
the ultra smooth package to make your
package the perfect package for this
summer step two you grab the crop
exfoliator infused with ingredients that
can soothe clear and keep the skin on
and around your groin feeling refreshed
the crop exfoliator can help reduce the
risk of ingrown hairs in your delicate
places you don't want ingrown hair
anywhere let alone in a delicate place
step three in the process crop gel see
where you're shaving with our unique
clear shaving gel just for the groin
with four essential oils it's like a spa
treatment every time you shave be good
to yourself boys and then step four of
course you shave the crop shaver was
designed for shaving the groin area with
confidence three precision blades
include extra wide lubricating strips
and a pivoting head for the ultimate
groin grooming experience this is the
good stuff so if you want to take
advantage of that and all the other
great products that manscape has to
offer uh you can get 20 off and free
shipping with the code omghi
manscape.com that is 20 off plus free
shipping with the code omghi
manscape.com
smooth out your fellas with the
relaunched ultra smooth package from the
fellas at manscape and your balls will
thank you
let me say this in 1979 there was a
comedian named billy brown
uh probably not around this [ __ ] 100
years ago and billy brown was doing a
stand-up
at the comedy store in westwood and
billy brown was talking about how
mexicans didn't look like they had feet
like they looked like they just went
around on wheels and they just kind of
he was doing the poses and stuff and
then three guys later i went up there
and i said uh this i'm [ __ ] 18 years
old yeah i said billy brown was up here
and he said that mexicans don't have
feet well he knows different because i
put this one in his ass
and they went crazy and that's the first
that's the first time
because i just started that i ever
thought about saying something about
somebody that went before me yeah yeah
and that's what i said that's why it's
like you know it's if you pay attention
beforehand you can play off that some
people don't like to pay attention
because then you get your head or you're
like oh i have a joke like that i can't
do that joke or they're not laughing
hard or just even pay attention on the
side though you don't have to be
but also man like you know
i think you're i think the way that you
think and the way that you are
is um
you love comedy right i do wouldn't you
go see this dude oh anywhere anywhere
because you just have that vibe man you
have a more confident vibe than people
that have been in here yeah they're more
they're more a little bit like uh uh um
they're not as uh
i would say
what would you say i i don't know what
i'd say i just know that he's
cool his confidence going up there and
how he plays off people and what he does
it's just knowing your acts and it takes
a long time to find what you are knowing
what the people
when you're playing to the people what
they want yeah i got a weird i got to
know early on in comedy when i first
moved here i auditioned for there was a
show at like flappers and and i didn't
audition there and i was getting laughs
and afterwards i asked the booker he was
doing like notes if you want notes and
and i and i went up there and i had a
good set and i was like five minutes
whatever and i was like so you know
cause i'm trying to get booked i was
like what do you think he's like he's
like you get laughs but they're not
there's nothing to it about you there's
no personalization and i got like mad i
was like what do you mean i was like i
did well right then i sat and i was like
man whatever he didn't give a [ __ ] and
then as i like grew on i was like
those jokes could have been from anyone
there's nothing unique to it about me
okay and then i like learned that it's
like it's gotta be you you wanna talk
about like you wanna talk about [ __ ]
that's crazy
so in the early 90s at caroline's i was
headlining the carolinas yeah and dave
becky came
and michael rotenberg was the head of
three arts and and chris rock
was represented by michael rotenberg and
i was and i was over there and dave
becky worked at the improv in san diego
and he was in new york and he said hey
can i come and see you and the guy in
the middle was kind of killing me every
night
and then we went backstage
at caroline's in the last room where i
saw gilbert you know a few years ago and
and and he said to me can i give you
some constructive criticism i said yeah
and he says you know when i watch you
there's nothing about you that tells me
anything about you like i don't know
what you like i know what your politics
are i don't know who you are i don't
know who your family is the same thing
sort of in [ __ ] the early 90s and he
said mundane and i was like [ __ ]
mundane yeah those words will hit you
like i don't know how to spell that
he goes there has to be somebody in your
family that had
something or you know he goes and he
said when i watch chris like when you
see chris rock you know what he's about
politically you know where he's at this
way you know he's not that and when i
see you i just don't see that same thing
the person said to you went back to the
hotel
and i thought
dad this [ __ ] is right first of
all you have to [ __ ] think that it's
right i started talking about my
grandmother i started talking about my
family and the rest this history is
i mean yeah
but it is a weird note because you're
like what do you mean i was funny the
people laughed but it's like but that's
remember you that's what it changes like
comedian versus like somebody who does
comedy so people get in the car we would
say we would say they get in the car and
they go hey that second guy was good huh
what did he say uh what about the guy oh
what about the guy that was talking
about
the milfs and they remember that yeah so
that's the [ __ ] that you want to be like
stories
yeah and and
nobody would on a mother's day well not
a lot of people would on mother's day
would go out there and say that yeah
it's risky
and sometimes i hit sometimes doesn't
like somebody like i went on uh uh when
i was on a conan in the 90s and and i
walked out there and i said hey man
latinos are a lot of different colors
you know we're blonde we have blue eyes
we're dark we're light skittles we'll
[ __ ] anybody but everybody's like
i thought it was funny i thought it was
funny
but but it's like when you take the risk
for yourself yeah nobody can tell you to
take the risk you can only give you the
advice oh yeah and whether you take the
risk or not
just like an instinct if you're a
detective you have an instinct that said
hey you know what i think this guy's
bullshitting me or have we talked to
this neighbor over here it's your
instinct that gets you by everything
really everything the confidence is key
if somebody told me like if you're not
confident in your own material why would
they be confident in you if you're
flubbing lines and you're shaky and you
don't know about a bit but you're going
to try it out they can read they can
read your facial expressions so when you
write stuff now that you're more than uh
how much time how much time do you think
you have like overall all in all
probably like
if we're talking all we're talking
everything probably like two hours
all right because on the road i do an
hour and and stop i mean if i pulled
everything probably over do you do an
hour on the road do you know an hour is
it the same hour or do you change it as
you i would say like 80 is the same and
then in the middle the middle is where i
throw in some new [ __ ] or i add some
tags that's where you got to i like this
guy
you know i was never got if because i
feel like if i'm never changing the set
i'm not growing as it can you record
every cent yeah audio and filming
you know i've been recording every set
since 1979. yeah oh yeah you listen to
it back and it's the most painful thing
ever i have i have uh cassettes remember
when you were in your car and you used
to have the case of cassettes when you
opened yeah yeah yeah yeah that's this
is how [ __ ] long i've er that's how
long i've been doing comedy
[ __ ] memorex [ __ ] tdk
cassettes i have with my [ __ ] on them
from
the comedy store
or the um
and that's audio or is that like vhs
it was even before vhf i mean that's the
best part because you riff a brand new
bit i just happened the other night i
forgot to hit record before i went up
because i thought i was in two and i got
called up ripped a whole bit
and i don't know how i did it and i
don't have the audio and i'm like let me
tell you this
in 1981
on a saturday night me and my friend
ernie got rest of seoul went to the
comedy store and there was a canary
yellow rolls royce i think i told the
story here in front of the in front of
the comedy store idling it was on and
somebody said that's richard pryor and i
said no it's not and i looked over far
away it was richard pryor so ernie said
go say hello to him and i
moved you know and when i got close
enough to see if it was richard pryor
he had a micro cassette recorder to his
ear and he was rewinding and forwarding
his set from the main room and i backed
up like this and he said what happened
and i said
i saw all i need to see he's working
and i didn't i didn't bother him that's
i let him work it's something awesome
when you see like the pros and the
legends doing the same thing that you do
or the same thing that they started out
doing i've seen bill bird go up at the
comedy store and he's got a notebook and
he's looking at it and he he has the
same look where he's like this this is
my bomb he goes all right let's try this
you know but it's the same
everything i find on this i love that
and you know what and then i eventually
you know knew richard pryor and thanked
him for and i told him that i'd seen
that but also yeah i was never a guy
that could take a note up because
i couldn't read that good in front of
people yeah you know or if i or if i
even had put notes down on the ground
that i thought i could read
in the in the emotion of doing stand-up
i would look down and just see a blur
yeah so i would be more of somebody that
that wanted to remember more things than
i could
oh yeah i mean i remember getting
started and stand up being like i can
barely remember five minutes how do
people do this for like an hour it's an
insane thing to remember all that but
it's just muscle memory you know it just
gets hammered away in your head so when
when like you remember why how do you
remember every date of every crime and
all that stuff that
well i i live like this
what day what day did you uh capture the
night soccer august 31st 1985.
boom
but you that your life revolved around
that event for so long
what did you do the next day
uh next day was september 1st my
my uh went back to work
we had had my cousin's wedding that
night you know i said oh [ __ ] you went
straight from that to the wedding yeah i
went straight from the right people just
bowing at you when you walked in they
they walked in there there was a nice
wedding it was at the pasadena hills
another beer couple and uh yeah and and
so
uh when i got there people were saying
oh that's him that's him that's him i
mean and i didn't know because i was
working i wasn't watching the news that
much
and
then i went in and i
saw my family we hugged and i saw my mom
imagine we cried
i said it's over with you know i hugged
my where's my wife she came down
and said hello and i told my cousin yeah
i told my wife i you know it's it's his
wedding
yeah i don't want to take anything away
from him i want to go up to the room i
want to be alone is he still married wow
uh she died
oh damn she died she her early
alzheimer's set in you know
so she's dead so he's still alive
so i'm sorry you know i said there's a
hundred times how do you guys know each
other
because of him following true crime the
oh wow you saw so you're big so a year a
year and a half ago when the night
stalker documentary went on netflix my
my publicist who's my friend said have
you seen the night stalker doctor i said
no i'd already seen it four times like
you know what's important i just want to
tell her no and then i said well i got
to get i got to get gil
on the show right so his partner frank
salerno on the documentary had worked
with me i i had him do something for me
in in 2010 29 2009
and i call frank
and he goes hello frank it's george
lopez hi hi you know very matter of fact
i said hey do you have a contact for gil
carrillo he's like
well i do i said can i give you my
number matt give it to him he's like
yeah and then
i think what somebody called me or did i
call that yeah
you put it out on your on the podcast
somebody a friend of mine called me up
in a sense
have you heard this
i just heard on the radio george lopez
said him and no gil carrillo gave mc
wants to give it so i called in i spoke
with george
first contact with him was about 35 45
minutes long
and we felt like we had known each other
forever yeah
really really good he wanted me to go
out golfing with him and
i don't golf i asked everybody if they
golf yeah i saw charles manson charles
manson come back for the dead
yeah but when george lopez you golf yeah
you'll learn you'll look up a youtube
video so you know i think we have a lot
of the same you know a lot of the same i
like that a lot of the same similarities
like you work very old school which a
lot of comedians don't yeah i would say
a lot of communities don't i think i try
to play both i try to do the no school
like mentality but also the same with uh
the new school like social media and
trying to like use that to like it's so
hard to like you think about if you're
just doing stand-up to an audience of
200 people every night like that's right
that's just 200 people you can see it
but you tape that set and that one weird
interaction you have with the
bachelorette party it goes viral that's
five million people seeing it it's like
that's right you know it's using both
play you never disrespect the field of
stand-up you know because you have that
respect for all that and coming up
through it and you respect it it takes
time to get good and i still think i got
years ago to get better but i've been
doing this like eight years so i'm like
let's just put a camera in there and see
what happens but you know but do you
know what makes somebody good i'll tell
you because i've been doing it for
uh 43 years damn
is that
you
when you're on stage
or when you're on a case
or whether you're a doctor or a [ __ ]
dentist or whatever you are
that the natural instinct that you have
you follow it yeah like if you have you
know because you know when you're up
there you might want to say something to
somebody and then for a minute you say
do i say it or do i not say it oh yeah
sometimes you say it and sometimes you
don't maybe you say it later yeah but
that navigation of your own uh triggers
or your own instincts is what's gonna
make somebody memorable as opposed to
somebody who right would say
i had the
if somebody came afterwards and said
that guy right there did that you go oh
man i was going to say something to him
but you didn't right and that's
different between somebody being great
and somebody being so so
hey everybody thanks for tuning in to
part one of this part two part episode
uh part two coming next week be sure to
check that out as always don't forget to
like comment subscribe just engage with
this content however you can it's really
helpful for george really helpful for
the show tell your friends tell your
enemies it doesn't matter as long as we
spread the word so thanks for checking
it out and we'll see you next time
you